In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon for April 30th, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle,
James, brother of St. John the Theologian.
On the 30th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Glorious Apostle, James,
brother of St. John the Theologian.
James was the Son of Zebedee and elder brother of St. John the Theologian and was a fisherman
with them in Galilee.
After the call of Andrew and Peter, he was called by the Lord with John his brother
to leave everything and follow him, immediately leaving their father and the boat with the
nets.
They followed Christ and showed such zeal that the Lord called them the sons of Thunder because
they had suggested that they call down fire on a Samaritan village that had refused
to receive them.
St. James accompanied the Lord on his preaching missions and was judged worthy of special
favor together with John and Peter.
Christ took them with him when he prayed and when he revealed his divinity in an especially
wonderful way on the day of his transfiguration on Mount Taibor.
When they were on the way to Jerusalem, James and John asked the Master through their mother
Salomei for two places of honor in his kingdom.
Jesus's answer to them was, you know not what he asked.
Are you able to drink of the cup that I shall drink of?
They say unto him.
We are able, and he sayeth unto them, ye shall drink indeed of my cup, but to sit on my
right hand and on my left is not mine to give, but it shall be given unto them for whom it
is prepared of my Father.
This prophecy was fulfilled after the descent of the Holy Spirit and the birth of the church
between the years 41 and 44.
Going to Jerusalem for the Jewish Passover, James was arrested on the orders of King Herod
Agrippa.
We are told that his jailor won over by the firmness of his witness and the order of his trust
in Christ the Savior begged the apostles forgiveness.
James embraced him, saying, peace be with you.
They were both then beheaded.
Saint James was thus the first of the twelve apostles to drink the cup of the Lord and
to go sit at his side in his kingdom.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.